if you look at why the google founders
are the google founders and still have
all this control over their company
you can look all the way back in time to
the at the moment of the earliest
fundraisers they were not desperate for
cash and load leveraged hey this is
michael seibel with dalton caldwell and
welcome to rookie mistakes we've asked
yc founders for their rookie mistakes so
we can share them with you and help you
avoid them okay so here's the next note
that ayc founder wrote in the easiest
way to fundraise is to indeed have a
good metric that's growing when i ran a
startup
that wasn't growing
i spoke to 140 investors and only got
two angel checks
now i'm working on a startup that is
growing and almost every well-known vc
is trying to figure out how to talk to
us it took us one week to raise our seed
round i don't know michael i i've heard
rumors
from around the world that the best time
to fundraise is before you have any
metrics at all
right because once you have any revenue
you will be judged on the revenue in all
like 97 of the time
the demo the product the mvp the mvp
with customers
gives you so much more leverage when
fundraising 97 of the time
well we talk about fear-based
decision-making a lot you and i do and
we talk about this with a batch and i
think a lot of times this is a case of
fear-based decision-making if in your
heart
you believe that your product is bad and
that you will fail
it makes a ton of rational sense to
fundraise
before the world figures it out and
before the world realizes
you know investors see that you launch
it and no one actually wants the thing
that you're making you know you know
that no one wants a thing you're making
in your heart right and so rather than
go and try to sell it and get what
you're expecting
to be really hard to sell
yeah you know it's gonna be a hard sell
so hey let's just raise before we go try
to do it not the best play you know the
other common failure path that we see
is
people putting the investor as the kind
of center of this game as opposed to the
customer
people thinking the investor is almost
the teacher and their job through a
pitch or to a deck is to get an a from
the teacher and the a's money i think
that
looking for validation from authority
figures is a lot of how we are
constructed to look at the world and if
you've been an employee or you've gone
to school your whole lives a lot of the
way you get ahead in life is to figure
out who the authority figure is that you
need to please
and if you please that authority figure
it's the path to greatness and so again
like if you're like a level
whatever
level three engineer at some big company
and you like the way you get ahead is to
impress the bosses
why not kind of pattern match that onto
startups not true if i could redirect
that energy towards pleasing people's
customers yeah people call this customer
obsession like it's a buzzword we're
customer obsessed but take let's take
that literally what does it literally
mean to be customer obsessed what it
literally means is most of your waking
hours
who are you thinking about pleasing
it's your customers and you're trying to
solve problems from them i think this is
a neat trick for an early stage founder
audit the amount of time you spent last
week talking to your customers
building product
right if that amount of time
in your waking day is like 80 to 90
percent you're probably doing it right
if that amount of time in your waking
hours or the last week is more like 20
percent you're probably doing something
very very wrong all right so here's the
next note that a yc founder wrote in
raise what you need and nothing more
you will find a way to spend all of the
money in your bank stay
lean and get your fundamentals right
you know
a lot of founders think money is like
oxygen and you need it to survive
you know
one of the things that um brian chesky
at airbnb told the batch recently is
maybe money's more like food you
definitely need food to survive but
in a lot of places in the world
including america people are dying from
too much food
as opposed to too little food
if you're afraid that bad things are
going to happen the idea of stockpiling
as much of whatever resources you can as
much as possible is totally sane and
reasonable
the issue is
really successful companies the oxygen
they have is revenue from their
customers and the they're being pulled
ahead by customer demand for their
product and that is providing the oxygen
of growth is like the pull of customers
it's funny because like those companies
tend to own more of their company
when they ipo or exit those founders
tend to be happier they tend to have
more innovation because if you don't
have as much money you got to innovate
you've got to do things better or
different than your competitors the
biggest difference between what founders
own more of their companies than than
others
is how
desperate they ever were in the history
of the company to need to raise money
and whether they were smart and had
leverage and they fundraised and so one
crazy story that i don't think most
people know is that facebook
was apparently always profitable that
even when it was a tiny college social
network
they had these ads on the site
way back in the day that made them
profitable
and so there was never around that
facebook was in trouble and raised on
poor terms or raised more money than
they needed and so i believe at exit
this is kind of
why zuckerberg owns so much of the
company
same with google google had incredible
traction this was a long time ago but i
used google when it was
google.stanford.edu
it was a really popular search engine
before they raised a single dollar
because they built it when they were
grad students and had tons of traction
and so the first money they raised was a
very good terms and every additional
round they raised after that they had
incredible leverage and so again if you
look at why the google founders are the
google founders and still have all this
control over their company
you can look all the way back in time to
the at the moment of the earliest
fundraisers they were not
desperate for cash and low leveraged i
think that you just hit on this like
secret hint to founders who you're
comparing yourself to matters
like if you're trying to hit a grand
slam home run with your startup compare
yourself to the people who have hit
grand slam home runs
instead of comparing yourself with like
a local peer group or the company that
just raised at a unicorn valuation
like other people in your pitch
competition yeah god like at a minimum
if you're looking for like heroes to
emulate can you copy companies that have
at least 100 million in revenue and like
preferably a billion there's like so
much more you can learn
from their stories even if they might be
old i guess you know facebook's an old
company now but even if they might be
older
man like you can learn a lot more and
like that's what you're trying to
emulate you're not trying to emulate the
unicorn valuation
you're trying to emulate the successful
multi-billion revenue company
yeah that's really well said michael
choosing
your peers and choosing
who you want to be like is one of the
most powerful things you can do if
you're an ambitious person that wants to
do things in the world is you get to
choose
who you want to be like
you